Okay. Let's just simply try and substitute our values in the
formulas that we know of. Since A and B are independent
events, the triangle probably is given by the product of A,
product of probability of A and B, so that gives us 0.25.
Probability of A given B, since A and B
are [UNKNOWN] of each other. Probability of A given
B is just probability of A, which is 0.5. So then the entropy of A is given by
this formula. And if we expand on this we get, we get the entropy of A as 1.
Similarly the entropy of B is also 1. What
is the joint entropy? The joint entropy is given as
this formula. So if we substitute the values we get the joint entropy of A
and B as 2. What is the condition entropy of A given B? It is given as this
formula. And if you substitute the values, we
get the conditional entropy as 1. Mutual information between
A and B is given by this formula.
And if we substitute the values of the variables
that we have already calculated, entropy of A and
entropy of A given B, we get 1 minus
1, which is zero. So, since the two coins
are independent, there is no mutual information between them.